RETWEET REGARDING THE CASE.
HERE WITH THE IS THE ATTORNEY
WITH US.
BY THE WAY, FULL DISCLOSURE, HIS
PARTNER LYNWOOD I HAVE RECENTLY
RETAINED AS ONE OF MY PERSONAL
LAWYERS.
I CONSIDER YOU GUYS THE BEST IN
THE BUSINESS.
TELL US ABOUT THIS CASE IN
PARTICULAR.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME ON.
THIS CASE WITH CNN AND THE
RETWEET THAT CAME OUT RECENTLY
TALKING ABOUT THE SETTLEMENT OR
CHARACTERIZING THE SETTLEMENT I
THINK WAS A BIG MISTAKE ON CNN’S
PART.
I DON’T THINK HE SHOULD HAVE
BEEN COMMENTING ON IT.
I THINK IT SHOWED POOR JUDGMENT
ON HIS BEHALF TO DO SO.
CLEARLY, HE DOESN’T HAVE ANY
IDEAS WHAT THE TERMS OF THE
SETTLEMENT ARE, YET SHOWED SOME
POOR JUDGMENT AND COMMENTING ON
IT NOT KNOWING WHAT HE WAS
TALKING ABOUT.
SURE.
>> Sean: DIDN’T MEAN TO
INTERRUPT YOU.
I’VE KNOWN HIM SINCE THE RICH
JEWEL CASE.
I WAS IN ATLANTA IN THAT CASE,
ONE OF THE FEW PEOPLE THAT
DIDN’T RUSH TO JUDGMENT, TAUGHT
ME A VALUABLE LESSON IN MY
CAREER.
I’M HONORED THAT HE HAS BEEN
ABLE TO RETAIN HIM AS MY OWN
PERSONAL ATTORNEY, HE IS GREAT
AT WHAT HE DOES, I KNOW ONE
THING ABOUT LYNWOOD IS INSTEAD
OF SAYING IT’S A NOMINAL SUM, I
DON’T BELIEVE THAT FOR A SECOND.
I KNOW YOU CAN’T DISCLOSE IT,
BUT I KNOW LYNWOOD.
HE WOULDN’T SETTLE FOR A NOMINAL
SUM EVER UNDER ANY
CIRCUMSTANCES.
DO YOU THINK I MIGHT BE IN THE
RIGHT, AND MY OVER THE TARGET?
>> AS YOU SAID, CAN’T REALLY
COMMENT AND WE DID AGREE NOT TO
CHARACTERIZE THE SETTLEMENT, BUT
I KNOW HE IS A FABULOUS LAWYER,
AND HE DOES GREAT WORK AND IT’S
A PLEASURE TO WORK WITH HIM ON
THESE CASES.
>> Sean: WHAT THEY DID TO THIS
YOUNG MAN, HE HANDLED ALL OF
THIS PERFECTLY, IS
UNCONSCIONABLE.
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN ME AND
THIS YOUNG MAN IS HE’S NOT A
PUBLIC FIGURE.
THIS IS MORE OF A SLAM-DUNK CASE
AND I BELIEVE THIS KID MIGHT
EVEN BE A BILLIONAIRE WHEN ALL